we have we have another gal tonight hi
Skye
oh yeah good what do you got for me
tonight
I know you're leading the way here so
you talked him off did he did he did he
Square you away did you have a question
or is there something that you wanted to
talk about
[Music]
the podcast is about okay yeah
contribute a little bit okay sure what
did you want to chime in on
um
specifically I guess
you have a disagreement with something
or no no no
um I guess specifically
listening
listening to there probably but okay
um what what does a boss [__] qualify
as you know what is a boss girl yeah
Diana was a boss girl for sure yeah
you're a little softer you've got a more
calm demeanor you know you only see more
feminine more you know like you're shy
in Sweden you know in that sense so what
so what brought you to the show like
what's the uh what's the topic that you
want to hit on like what did you want to
talk about
hmm I suppose for me specifically
there's a bit of a dichotomy there
you think that I am a little bit you
know more feminine and softer but
um
uh recently I went on a date I'm 31 by
the way okay I've been married
um unfortunately it was not a great
great marriage
um so I've been single for
you know probably going on three years
now
um lots of moves I did grad school I did
you know a fellowship post-grad
fellowship and stuff so very ambitious
career-wise I suppose what do you do for
a living
I'm an epidemiologist
okay and scientists you know I love I
love my data okay gotta grow a bit of an
engineer and your marriage you remember
married before you said for how long for
three years okay and why did that end
um so we were both military
um a little bit of anger issues on his
end unfortunately and it was just you
know something he wasn't willing to work
on I suppose so
um yeah but I I guess recently something
that kind of like uh
really threw me through a loop I suppose
um I went on a date with someone who
like precursed with like oh I love
feminine women
the great whatever we're talking
everything's vibing whatever you know
halfway through the day I mentioned in
the military
it was kind of a a big turn off for this
person
um so yeah I guess
I guess the dichotomy there for me is
something I've
so it was like a one date and he said
I'm not into military girls did he give
a reason why no no
you did not okay so what are you finding
hey
it's just sucker that The Vibes changed
a little bit okay so what are you
finding in the dating world when you're
getting out there like what are you
struggling with
um so I live in Florida I'm in Tampa
Florida okay
um South Florida right so a lot of just
very casual dating I suppose has been a
been a thing here for me
um so finding more like commitments I
suppose
uh more meaningful less superficial has
been difficult what does meaningful look
look like versus superficial
Egypt's not like dating a ton of people
all at once
yeah but that's going to take some time
though right I mean if you want a guy to
get I mean if you want a guy to commit
to you over long-term like what's the
plan you want a boyfriend you want a
family like what's your what's your
dating strategy
um yeah I mean right now I'm taking it a
step at a time I just went from a
boyfriend this
is and you're not getting stuck in dates
like what generally happens when you're
going out with the guys that's no I'm
definitely getting second dates but it's
um
I don't know I guess there's a it's
difficult for me to decipher coming from
right so I was in a seven year
relationship and you know post divorce
different dating World completely
different dating World
um I guess
2020 and on obviously the pandemic and
everything plays into that culturally
and everything
um
but yeah I think
like maneuvering like what is the point
in time like you know like when do you
expect me to stop dating other people
sorry my cat's being
she likes camera time too I suppose
how many cats do you have
yes okay
I got her when I was in the military
it's like easier to leave alone for a
few days okay okay
um yeah so as far as what of what your
strategy is looking like I mean you're a
soft kind sweet smoking woman
um you definitely sound feminine you're
a contrast to Diana you know our last
caller who was very uh intentional with
her wording and her Direction
um so you will probably find that you're
gonna you're gonna be able to enter the
frame of a strong guy a lot easier than
a guile gal like Diana I don't know why
why the military would have turned that
guy off I know that there's there's uh
I mean it's been said before but a lot
of people say that women from the
military have uh a typical uh Avatar do
you know what that is
um
uh well I mean I don't know specifically
but I imagine like what do they used to
say about like military girls
oh gosh very like
I mean I've I was in the military I've
met a lot of military women I understand
that stereo for her
yeah are you that gal
it's like very like strong dominant and
you know
um no I don't think so not good no I
don't think so uh I mean I mean I wish I
could be more useful to you sky but I
mean it's it's it's difficult getting to
the root of what it is that you're
struggling with I mean it's usually
somebody calls in and they're like well
I have a disagreement and I have a
better solution here's it is or I have a
problem you know what do you think I
should be doing it doesn't sound like
you've got any real issues because
you're able to get dates
um they're not turning into anything
long-term for you just yet but
but it's kind of a numbers game like for
for men when they look at women
generally speaking Sky they look at
women as Beauty objects they look at
them of of of something as value-like
the most valuable woman to a guy tends
to be a woman that can't that won't just
be with anybody and just wants to be
with that one guy right like they like
they want to know that they like they
own her
okay they don't want a woman to be like
running around and being used up by
another by a whole bunch of guys right
so it's important for a gal like you
that's softer and feminine to preserve
her value as you sort of date and be
intentional about and be clear and just
be clear like hey you know this is what
I'm looking for this is what I do I have
a orange cat over here she kind of gets
annoying when I use FaceTime whatever uh
and just you know carry on with it but
only deal with guys that are willing to
you know go down the same path that
you're looking to go down but you need
to find a leader you're a lastborn right
you're a lastborn
do you have siblings
yeah like you're very easy like you
strike me as a kind of check that's like
from California like very like you know
it doesn't matter it's all good sort of
thing I'm like 35 hippies yeah hippie
that's it that's it yeah I mean like
you'll do just fine if you got your [__]
together you're kind you're feminine you
know you find a strong masculine guy and
just be a compliment to his life what
can I do to be useful you know yeah I
suppose it's like hard to find that
balance though you know like Believe It
or Not Skye guys love it when women say
hey what can I do to be useful a few
dates in you know and take the
initiative to show that you want to
complement their lives right
if it's something as simple as making
the bed do it you know if it's something
like you know grabbing a pile of laundry
throw it in the machine do it guys like
I don't
I guess like what is so difficult for
men to like lean into like just talking
about those things though like there's
where you can help me what is it they
don't they don't typically lean in stuff
like that because guys aren't guys are
taught to share their feelings their
Fifi's and they go about it the wrong
way so that's why you end up with this
like
category of softer weaker men today and
they'll just show up and they're
socially awkward they're uncalibrated
they'll last the wrong questions at the
wrong time the Laughing giggle like
dorks you know and make bad jokes and
you'll look at them funnily and be like
well he seems like a nice guy maybe I'll
keep him as a backup plan if I can't
find anything else sort of thing and you
put them in like the back rotation sort
of thing or you you know you keep them
in your phone just in case later on
don't like be intentional you know date
guys that you're attracted to be a
compliment to their life you're you're
the exact kind of girl that a strong
virtuous guy would want to invite into
his life
if you can compliment it
guys are in the chat right now with
their jokes saying can you make a
sandwich
oh my goodness yes I do are you a
feminist guy you don't strike me as a
feminist
um I mean I need to leave like
I believe in equality for sure yes but I
believe there's like men and women are
equal today you know let's be honest
things that men bring to a relationship
and that women bring to a relationship I
truly believe that the Ying it's the
Yang it's the compliment to a man's life
and he's able to lead you through it
sort of thing that's what that's the
ideal scenario that's the ideal that's
that's what I encourage men to do skies
I tell them to freaking leave I tell
them to make something out of themselves
I tell them to be competent it's very
easy as a woman to like you know if
you're like navigating the world on your
own like to have to feel like you have
to step into like some masculine
a little bit
um
I guess energy right so that you're not
you will have to do that if you run into
a soft guy
don't do that just don't deal with soft
guys because two soft people don't work
out two headstrong people don't work out
it's a union right you know you want a
guy to lead you're already a soft gal
there's a lot of strong leaders out
there just look for that guy
hmm
sounds good
good luck with this guy we'll talk to
you later all right
take care I really hope you guys enjoyed
that clip if you want to watch the full
length podcast you can find that over
here that clips from if you're new to
the channel make sure you hit subscribe
over here and pin down below in the top
comment you'll find a bunch of useful
links to my website my supplement line
books and a bunch of other stuff have an
amazing day peace out